hallo leute ich finde einfach und
willkommen zu einem wald bei 3 comics
dyballa beruf mich da an die vorwehen
des nächsten team spielt setzen ein mit
dem handy verbunden moment war das ist
nervig
[Musik]
und da sage ich herzlich willkommen zu
einem drei cocktails und schaller
es ist ja alles ganz wie das popcorn ein
gurke oder ein einmal kleider es freut
mich sehr dass er mit dabei seid
wirklich es ist es ist sehr lieb ich hab
ja auch aber ich wollte nur sagen nur
weil zu lange her ist heißt es noch
lange nicht dass ich euch nicht fest
[Musik]
ich weiß gar nicht wann die letzte folge
online gegangen ist die letzte folge
drei conti- wahlamt ist glaube ich im
januar 2020 besser noch nicht symptomen
wer in dieser zeit anzupassen
der staat jetzt einfach mal mit dem
thema das thema heute sind
konservendosen und wir müssen einen
cocktail machen der zum lockdown passt
aber auch konservendosen beinhaltet
dosen eine seite lang briefing die alten
bürgerschaft heraus lenken soll er zum
hans dann zum kurve zum lockdown bruder
um die illusion von beständigkeit und
ordnung im leben aufrechtzuerhalten
ihr sollt euch auch in der farbe ihres
kopfes anziehen ich hoffe das hat mir
gemacht passt ja total
wir stellen unsere zutaten vornamen
hoffe ihr habt euch mühe gegeben und ich
bin das ich bin sehr froh dass ich meine
zutaten noch nicht sehen können weil
jedes mal bevor wir anfangen rente die
erstmal darüber bestehen
ich habe mir auch nicht stehen steht vor
die eis sie war ich nicht durch ja ich
sag jetzt schon vanessa abstand deutlich
die meisten konzerten von uns gekauft
weil die hat eingelegte früchte gekauft
den kunden geholfen verletzte kräftig
alles querbeet saß auch schon vorhin
einmal gesagt aber ich glaube du bist
auf einen ganz großen wolltest weg aber
wer ausführt wir werden daraus und gilt
als fachmann
ja wir aber wo steht eigentlich immer
rechts von mir steht freddy oder die
dusche ich mal rechts von mir ja richtig
dass auch lustig wenn wir reden dann
könnte ich auch okay
wir stellen uns zu versagen ist einfach
und doch irgendwie sagen als ich mit
rest in peace
meine konservendose mandarin dahin kommt
er noch mehr wissen es nicht
also ich bin eine negative spur auf der
spur gewesen und habe ich
rotkäppchen-sekt gefunden
aber da steht laschen gärung und dann
dachte ich moment mal flaschengärung
sagt mir was
also ist das quasi champagner daher
nicht so heißen die pro version davon
quasi und investigativer journalismus
und mein zweiter alkohol ist lee und
morgens mein dritter alkohol ist am 3
und dann habe ich noch zum mixen wie
orange und das habe ich auch schon mal
probiert das sehr lecker welter oder
mineralwasser an die schläfe zu tage
aber ganz ehrlich orangen mit mandate
hinzu mission ist es nicht so ein
bisschen wie so wandeln mit mandeln
milch essen lieber gott vielen dank dass
du mir die kraft gibt es die wahrheit zu
sagen hat sich so ein bisschen pervers
dann sind bürger mandarin orange er noch
mal ganz kurz zurückspulen hat freddy da
etwa gerade was gesagt danke danke dann
gibt's noch orangenmarmelade und
softbank im geschmack orange also ich
bin jetzt verwirrt weil die mandarinen
so prominent vorgestellt hast und jetzt
zu sein das team aber doch eher so dass
frankfurt mich ein bisschen ja also mein
gott so geriebene orangenschale was hast
du denn
momentan hat die noch ein jahr lang
[Gelächter]
ich habe sogar noch altes fleisch vom
letzten jahren genutzt was ist mit dir
ich hab mandarin eiswürfel gemacht was
wo sie damals zu sagen was nie passiert
wäre wenn wir in köln alles
zusammengenommen hätten dann hätte ich
niemals die zweite bürger haben ich habe
ihnen eingebrochen
möchtest du vielleicht macht man ich
habe die ganze nacht war es im prinzip
wach und darüber nichts anderes
nachgedacht mein mann hat so passiert ja
nichts mehr
der ganze schublade mandarinen
vorbereitet
ich habe malibu hier da steht drauf dass
ich glaube dass das verfallsdatum
arbeiter steht 89 drauf könnte sein das
ist den ich seit 89 für diesen moment
macht es jetzt drauf jetzt kommt mal
einkaufen ist bereit
jetzt warte ich hatte letztens placement
ich habe letztens lassen und erst mit
penny müsst ihr kurz noch mal kannst du
noch kauft dann schreibe ich ja den
paceman mit kaufland ok kaufland gut ich
habe den ich dachte ich mach mal was mit
obst das habe ich noch nie gemacht haben
erdbeeren aber die mit viel plastik weil
ich hasse kleine baby schildkröten
dann habe ich noch eminems weil das
gehört für mich einfach dazu
russland dann sehr wichtig zu müssen
habe ich orangina und dann hatte ich ein
bisschen panikreaktionen und habe
einfach das erste gegriffen was vor mir
stand und das ist jetzt fünf frucht
cocktail dastand cocktail drauf und es
ist eine konserve von simon kock das war
alles was in meiner in meiner
menschlichen to-do-liste im kopf es war
so man da denke ich an ibiza geile
frauen alkohol also hochmut kommt vor
dem fall
das ist mein hd video vanessa wusste
dass die anderen beiden fruchtcocktails
machen und ist ein wie einfachste
konserve nehmen ja und zwar obst
deswegen habe ich mir vorgenommen kein
obst als konserve schon meine ich muss
einmal dazu auch sagen leute sie macht
wieder zu den tomaten scheiße nicht
erwartet doch bitte hier
der wodka den nicht wählte im kiosk der
ist so geil und ersten liga das heißt
ich feierabend auch noch etwas auf ich
habe hier noch tabasco
[Musik]
also wir können sie ja schon vorgestellt
nein naja manchmal dass er mal in folge
wie ich das möchte wann es war eine zeit
zu zeit ist tabasco so meine drohte zu
tag ist tomaten stück ich damit liegt
ihr absoluter richtig in eurer vermutung
dass ich etwas mit einem tomaten
cocktail macher allerdings wäre das ja
nur eine klassische mary bloody mary das
ist doch mal ein bisschen wie viele
leute da draußen gerne bloody mary
trinken oder mexikaner short der ich bin
ich bin einer davon nicht ganz ganz
schlecht ja und ich glaube viele da
draußen verurteilt sie bitte nicht auch
und ich glaube man merkt auch dass
keiner von uns diesen cocktail cayston
kann deswegen ist höchstwahrscheinlich
wollten zuschauer liegend seine
verteidigung versuchen so viele punkte
wie möglich einzuhalten
weil das was jetzt als nächstes kommt
mag vielleicht nicht logisch aussehen
aber ich dachte mir bloody mary ist
etwas langweilig und dann dachte ich so
was passt sind in diesem gemüse mixed
noch ein und ja ich mache es kurz und
schmerzlos ich habe sauerkraut gekauft
[Applaus]
nur ich nicht so ein langweiler und ein
scheiß obst cocktail machen wir zwei
lisa ja da verrät cocktail draufladen du
nimmst es raus ich bin eher der typ ich
mache mir nicht so gerne so einfach ja
also wir stellen unser auftritt vor
[Musik]
forscht.de wenn ihr könnt ihr auch auf
angekauft sind gerade das gewürz
hinzukriegen
danke vanessa erscheint sicher für sich
mit ihr gesucht und es gab es nicht
deswegen habe ich den anderen kommt er
nicht umhin fangen wir an
ach so ja und dann begrüßen euch
herzlich zu den weg gab
die durch viele beginnt mein gott ich
habe jetzt so ein schönes neues glas
gekauft tolle sache
seine sprüche kotzen mich wirklich
mittlerweile an wie können wir erzählen
was ist denn bei euch letztens so
passiert in den letzten wochen monaten
jahren
jetzt wieder so toll und ich muss
einfach sagen ich freue mich einfach so
krank viel zeit löffel drogen zu haben
das gefühl jeden abends ein mailing
leute hätten diesen sound er ist wichtig
wo ich krieg den gleichen test wie wie
bei vanessa in der alten wohnung gerade
direkt in meinem und verlud genau sowas
schon mal gemacht und dann ist man
besser kotzen gegangen ja das ist genau
das gleiche gewesen
auf meiner wird richtig scheiße da ist
gar kein sauerkrautsaft darum oder doch
damit ihr auch seht hier drückt man
einfach nur ein bisschen in
sauerkrautsaft aus der dose aus ich kann
ich kann nicht im kopf
es ist 20 21 niemand ist mir auch meine
ich habe hier nämlich orangenmarmelade
und da werde ich mein glas wein trinken
mit zucker und ganz ehrlich macht auch
immer das gleiche
das sind aber wir stehen dazu heute
dagegen sprechen die irgendwas 50 folgen
jetzt die bâloise weil ja auch nicht mal
was von tomaten cocktail ich mir aus dem
arsch ziehen soll
ich hoffe mainz movie maker kann ein
bisschen quatschen sonst aber zum
problem
sonst einfach gut zusammen
hey
ich weiß nicht ob es eine gute idee ist
es riecht auf jeden fall die angst um
ich habe jetzt gerade die anderen das so
klein geteilt wird
aber das jetzt wirklich 73
[Gelächter]
ich hab noch nie und püriert ich habe
noch nie und püriert ich hab noch nie
operiert ich habe noch nie studiert ich
habe noch nie studiert ich hab noch nie
aus pürierten skonto geil dass mainz
movie maker auch eiswürfel püriert
was vanessa was soll ich da noch mal war
den habe ich mit meiner musik
also kennen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe gar nichts gesagt hat ich bin
so einer kann sich gar nicht vorstellen
warum bei uns entspannt ich will hier
ist mein leben beide male möchte ich
noch sagen
von st
[Applaus]
denn wir sorgen
sie überließen die westfalia von mega
gut ich wollte auch dubai fliegen ja was
ist denn in dubai
aber ich bin ganz ehrlich wenn sie auch
schon da ich belassen wie lange shisha
bars zusätzlich kann gewusst und auch
[Musik]
heute abend erst mal schön ein rein
schießen
[Musik]
ich bin mein glas rein also ich muss
sagen ich habe heute schon abgeliefert
man sieht auch schön außen
man sieht aus wie von seinem elfjährigen
fordert spieler absagen durch kommt
[Musik]
jetzt wieder die sektflasche aufgemacht
und trinken das war ganz schön bekloppt
die haben es gar nicht gehört noch nicht
gehört ich bin fertig musste nur meinen
sauerkraut in meinem glas einfügen
obwohl ich sagen muss das erinnert an
den vier sagt frank von harry potter
kommt eis meint cocktail okay dann zeigt
ihnen in eure kamera das habe ich so
nicht auch schon so müssen wir jetzt
gleichzeitig okay jetzt alle zeigen
schön wie in flames in die hand blogger
dahinter
[Musik]
okay wir probieren jetzt erstmal dann
stellen wir ihn vor nachladen oder einem
zweiten fall
achso nacheinander oder als wäre das ein
erziehungscamp ihr ja okay ich brauche
zuerst probieren ihre mama mach doch mal
einfach du als gast auf deinem channel
und mir doch ein ja von den orangen
schlimme vergessen
vergessen scheinen gut was passiert hier
gerade kommt eine sehr starke champagner
note durch und man schmeckt aperol und
ist die lehre ist also das ist so ein
sehr stark alkoholischer das ist so ein
glas was so 13 euro im jahr kostet und
ist sich danach seien genau die menge
ist extrem wenig aber die booms qualität
ist sehr
ansonsten ist es ein sehr orangina
cocktail also man trägt sich nicht
kannte und ein bisschen vanille in die
fresse und ich finde das ist ein tolles
und rankweil wenn man sich so einsam
fühlt und bisschen fancy fühlen möchte
für den doktor
das ist der lockenkopf für mich ist
lockt dann für euch ist kock daun
weil wenn du zu viel davon kriegen es
geht doch gucken immer hoch bleibt und
nenne den kotten ein bisschen bei demenz
und danach weiter mandy
das ist der name kelly oder ist ein
stück sauberer sport nach oben gekommen
mike so ein bisschen nach tomate
geschmack ist sehr präsent und dieses
sauerkraut macht alles der name schon
sagt etwas sauer
dazu kommt noch durch die nase so
essiggurken geschmack mit hinzu ohne
dass man die es sich coco wirklich
konsumieren muss alternativ für dich
forschern kann auch ein trost zu seinem
cocktail essen da brat und mein cocktail
heißt loca
ok to gute guter name finde ich kenne
jetzt auch mal muss man auch mal sagen
das ist ein gutes wort schrie du hast
die pdf gelesen
[Applaus]
hier ist mein cocktail der ist fruchtig
meunier auf das comeback habe so ein
bisschen
ich habe hier oben ananas muss drauf
damit er die nms darauf können und unten
drunter sind frische erdbeeren und
cocktail früchte weiß nicht ob die kennt
aber ist die fünf früchte kopf süße
player auf jeden fall bin ich ganz
ehrlich
die konserven sagt mitbenutzt ja
bisschen aber ist auch leicht sauer muss
ich sagen also das verstehe ich das
irritiert mich gerade ein bisschen weil
ich würde sie sich etwas sauer daran
sollte ja und schokoladig süß aber nicht
ohne grund heißt dieser cocktail dabei
weil das was mich in diesem lockdown an
richtig viel spaß erinnert ist natürlich
dabei weil dann gesehen wenn ich
wirklich gar keinen bock mehr habe und
weil ihm vielleicht durchgehalten habt
im lock down und aus so schlecht geht
uns hier noch mal ein rabatt mir
vielleicht stück für dual günstiger
kriegt ja keiner und er wechselt auf
jeden fall auch die ganze die farbe der
war mal gelb oder grün ja kennt ja schon
richtig gefragt wie machen wir das denn
jetzt mit der bewertung das ist
natürlich ein bisschen schwierig
wir können nicht den kopf der von
anderen probieren das machen wir dieses
mal so dass ihr hier oben oder da oben
dann abstimmen könnt welche hat für euch
eure meinung nach gewonnen ich würde
sagen ich bin ich bin für kelly dieses
mal 24 uns wieder leute in dubai war
doch schön
wir haben es jetzt ja auch der zuschauer
sich irgendwie auch erlebt würde sagen
es ist jetzt zeit für das große finale
diesmal mit mir singen es klingt als ob
du mich versetzt wäre ja das geht nicht
anders online geht es nicht gut mit ihr
[Musik]
nach unserem guten systems ios aus
mal raus meine art gewonnen